this is a production of Cornell
University
familiar faces
I've been with uh Wyoming County still
in water for 10 years like Jenny said
full disclosure in Wyoming County
through the funding programs we've
implemented one cover and flare system
in Wyoming County so far and that was
back in 2017 and actually fortunate
enough to work with all the people that
have presented today on that project so
um The Soil and Water aspect of of this
whole system is pretty much we're kind
of the uh kind of the middleman when it
comes to it all
um
and we work between
the farm and engineers and contractors
and state committee for funding
um kind of the the go-between for it all
so
um
as Dale and Jennifer Clifford mentioned
um
the whole basis where it begins is
agricultural Environmental Management
um that's a it's a structured program
here in New York state that allows us to
work with Farms to you know inventory
where they're where they're currently at
um as far as Environmental Management
goes
see where they are some of the strengths
are on a farm and other areas that maybe
we can help them improve upon you know
it's it helps us plan with the farm
um
what opportunities are out there for
them to be better stewards of the land
um
as well as uh you know what they are
doing good already it's just a it's a
process that allows us to to constantly
track where a farm is uh is moving and
it's it's the Baseline structure for for
when funding availability comes around
um
with these plans AEM plans in place it
allows us to possibly you know hand pick
the Farms that uh that possibly certain
systems could work good for when when
funding does become available for these
systems
so first thing that we try to consider
with with Farms is uh
you know we're constantly doing
agricultural Environmental Management
with Farms throughout the course of of
the year you know 365 days
um
and always discussing different
Pest management practices that Farms
could could possibly implement
we always try to bring up cover and
flare systems on particular Farms um
as it it's really shown how much savings
um it can help with not only financially
for the farm but also reducing methane
release into the atmosphere
um
called clean water savings so all those
things come into into play you know as
we're talking with Farms about these
different systems um
but I will say that probably one of the
biggest
factors that you can't can't necessarily
measure or calculate is the management
structure of a farm
um
I know the the goal is to have cover and
flare systems on on every single Farm in
New York state in a period of time
um and possibly we will get there
um but I will say that you know some of
the Farms that we we work with maybe
don't have the management structure in
place to implement a system like this
it's a it's a relatively complex system
um
that does require a high level of
management when it's all said and done
that being said uh you know there's
there's great farms out there everywhere
that uh that I think could benefit from
this uh this system
so prior to applying for funding
um
we work with the farm one to figure out
hey is this a is this A system that
would be worthwhile to your farm is it
something you think you'd handle
um
so we help the farm to calculate how
much methane these systems would would
eliminate and how the farm possibly
could track that
will help them calculate
the gallons of rainwater saved from
going into a manure storage that all
helps in the bottom line not only for
reducing the dilution of of the
nutrients in a manure storage so that
that a farm would then later have to
haul you know it cost money to haul this
manure so all of it all that plays into
the whole factor of everything
we talked with the farm about how
how the system could help increase the
Farm's resiliency
we here in the in New York state Western
New York obviously we're in the snow
belt we get a lot of snow as well as a
fair amount of precipitation throughout
the spring summer and fall
um
part of the factor that goes into that
is
you know manure storages when uncovered
do collect precipitation so
should we get a uh a heavy rain event
and the farm hasn't been able to haul
manure there is
free board built into every uh
every manure storage to allow for a
certain size storm
but it can put
certain situations it can put Farms on
pins and needles because they possibly
haven't been able to remove manure from
their uh their storage recently and all
of a sudden we get three inches of rain
and they're constantly worried about
their storage over topping
um
fortunately it's just the one of the
natures of beasts when it comes to it
um we also talked to the farm about what
other component practices might be
necessary to implement this system as uh
as the other presenters have said you
know solid separation is is key to this
um
you know you
not just throwing on a
thrown on a cover and flare and calling
it good you know you have to have a way
to to remove solids from the manure
before it enters there
as well as water removal from the cover
um you know there's
there's various ways that have been
discussed today as to how you can remove
water and utilize that water there's
also very simple ways to uh to remove it
we also work with a farm to
get them in contact with a professional
engineer because probably one of the
biggest factors when it comes to
applying for funding
for a system like this is what is it
going to cost
um
and we can we can help calculate for
that that for the farm but a lot of
those numbers will probably come from a
professional engineer or other
professional staff out there to uh
to determine that because
the um
when it comes to funding we've discussed
the cost share rates you know it's
important for the firm to uh
to determine what cost share rate they
they are able or willing to contribute
um these systems are not not cheap but
at the same time you know that there has
to be some buy-in from the farm and
possibly that's the uh the minimum 20
through the CRF program or possibly it's
50 50. um I know it's all
all things that we discussed with the
farm prior to uh prior to applying for
the funding
so when a RFP is released requests for
proposals is released for CRF or AG
non-point Source we then begin to
put everything together there's
significant documentation that that
needs to be put in place for for all
these programs
um
so we spent a lot of time doing that and
then
all these projects across New York State
anyways are are ranked and then the top
rank projects typically get funded so we
were fortunate enough on round one of
the
climber's Lane farming program to get
funded for cover and flare system
that particular system as you can see
here it was a retrofitted Earthen waste
storage
um
so after the uh after we
got news that the
the application was funded you know it
takes time for us to develop contracts
between
New York State Ag and markets and the
district and then also between the
district and the farm
so we then after contracts are in place
we've been working with the
uh the farm and the professional
engineer to develop final final designs
for the system
from there there's a solicitation
bid solicitation requirement with these
grants essentially trying to make sure
that taxpayer money is getting utilized
as fast as they can
so we help the farm with bid development
and solicitation um
once once contractors are selected after
that fact we will set up a
pre-construction meeting with all
parties involved and that's typically
the engineer the farm contractors the
soil Water Conservation District and
possibly nrcs if they're involved or
anybody else for that matter that the
farm or
team I think is uh is necessary excuse
me
so after construction begins
um the district serves as
we provide construction inspection on on
these projects
this particular one the engineer was uh
was not located
not super close by so we assisted the
engineer by
ducting construction inspections of the
project just to ensure that everything
was being built to spec
um
you know and we document everything
photographically typically as well as
keep a daily log
of any progress that's been made
and all that's important because at the
end when the project is complete some of
this information is necessary for the
closeout of the uh of the grant so
we also
select all the bids because all that
needs to be recorded as well as invoices
um
voices received by the farm from the
contractors we collect copies of all
those as well as proof of payment to
show that the contractors have been paid
at the end of all that
since the project is built and complete
we also receive engineering
certification
essentially the engineer signing off
that the project is complete and meets
standards and specifications
so after it's complete again we uh we
need to document
all proof of payment and invoices
that ties back into the the cost share
rate it allows us to determine
um how much reimbursement the farm is
going to get um
you know if the project cost a million
dollars and they went
70 state funded and 30 percent landowner
in kind you know we can reimburse them
for up to 70 of the uh
of the incurred cost
we also as part of the uh the programs
be it Agnon point source or climbers and
farming we have to develop a final
report that is then sent off to egg and
markets for final approval
um
and then we consistently are are
assessing the project to see what kind
of setbacks there may have been or
areas of the project that were a big
success
um that ties back into agricultural
Environmental Management in the end part
of AEM is
um
reviewing projects that have been
completed in the past to determine okay
are they still functioning as they
should be are there maintenance issues
that need to be addressed things of that
nature
um
and it's it's a constant learning
process with all these all these
projects um you know it's these cover
and flare systems have been around for a
little while now but there's still
learning curves that uh that need to be
made so we're constantly working on that
with the farm and with Engineers to
determine hey is there a better way that
we can do this um
no
the uh the one farm that we've
implemented a cover and flare system on
one of the uh unexpected outcomes that
they've seen from it that really hasn't
affected things too much for the farm
but um
they noticed an increase of birds
particularly seagulls we'd like to spend
time on top of the uh the cover it's
probably a little bit of a heat source
for them
so they um they've been dealing with a
lot more bird species around the farm I
guess due to that so
kind of a nutshell again the The Soil
and Water Conservation District is is
kind of the go-between for for a lot of
the parties involved in these projects
and um
I will say that the uh the one project
that we implemented here in Wyoming
County has been a it's been a great
success the farm is very happy with it
it's um it's been a highlight for us for
for some time now and
like to uh I'd like to do another one so
that's about all I have Jenny
oh that was fantastic I would like for
you to do another one also
um
uh can you just uh can you just just as
one question uh
this is we are currently in February of
2021 do you think uh given given time uh
somebody could apply February 2022 when
round seven of the CRF may or may not
come out
is that realistic
um you mean February of 2023 oh right
yes
yeah I think that's very realistic
um it's uh
projects that um
it's been
to be quite honest the first one that we
and only one that we did um
here in Wyoming County we had planned on
we hadn't had a whole lot of interest I
guess in the area and uh the farm that
we implemented on came to us relatively
I don't want to say last minute but in a
very short time frame and um
fortunately we were successful in that
application and completed it in a very
short time frame that being said it was
not um
not the easiest to
pull together in such a short time frame
but we did it
um
moving forward definitely a year
would be much better for for ironing out
some of the uh the issues with it and
determining just what kind of things are
going to be necessary for for providing
an application for funding
so uh
Wyoming County now has you very skilled
Jennifer if I could add to that
if I could add to that if the budget
comes through the way it looks like
they're proposing there is going to be a
very large increase of money for covers
and flares on the next round in 2023
so we're going to need a lot more
applicants
awesome
um so Alex depilis asked a question but
maybe it was from last it's two it's old
um thinking about the cost we're gonna
yeah these are old questions all right I
would like to open it up for anybody who
has any last comments that they would
like to make
um after hearing everybody else's
presentation I I just want to give all
of these wonderful speakers first just
thank you so much for coming and sharing
your expertise and hard work
um if anybody has any comments that they
would like to
ad please feel free
um and thanks
um also there's a poll out there so if
you could just share what you felt about
this uh webinar
that would be great
and um
uh Alex De pillis has raised his hand
Alex Jennifer can you help me figure out
how to get Alex to speak
check check breaker one nine let's see
hi so that wasn't an old question and
I'll just boil it down Jennifer this
work is great that you did you know turn
me onto this thing with your wonderful
paper which I dropped into the questions
there but question is you know it's five
years later whatever since you wrote
that stuff and and you know thinking
about cost per gallon of storage for
cover and Flair what's a reasonable
range these days I mean I'm trying to
boil it all down to a number here
cost per gallon of storage
Alex okay whatever that's okay no
problem I I will say that the cost for
greenhouse gas mitigation is between uh
nine and fourteen dollars per metric ton
and that for society is one of the
lowest cost greenhouse gas mitigation
strategies that we have
um besides the cost-effective like feed
efficiency and and
um
and nitrogen use efficiency which are
just common sense reductions of
greenhouse gases through through
efficiency
um so I can't tell you on the cost per
per gallon
offhand
sorry 10 years ago 10 years ago it was
seven cents for ours okay but it also
bans on the depth of the storage the
deeper you are the more gallons you have
not just area size
okay
Dale had you know just in the future can
we ask to sort of think about the total
finances on on it meaning the water
hauling savings plus
um plus the betting savings etc etc
is that something that maybe we could
scrounge up in order to think about the
sort of whole Farm financial plan of
this
I can put figures together on our farm
okay I think that might be useful right
because there's all these co-benefits
and so it's sort of counter balances
you know that the single sticker price
and
just so everybody knows uh the new uh
CRF is giving an 80 car share for this
um
okay
Peter do you have a comment
Mr chime in I I do think kind of the
cost case study that also
just briefly lists kind of the before
and after of the equipment I think
developing ideally two or three of those
would probably be super helpful for
people every Farm is different but but
having some real examples I think really
makes it real for folks who haven't
really delved into it
go ahead
for just
um the farm that we implemented at
implemented the project on here in
Wyoming County
um
they had an existing Earth and storage
but they had to build a separation house
to one separate the salads from the
affluent as well as the cover and Flair
the overall
cost per gallon on that particular
project was around 17 or 18 cents per
gallon
my cost was only the cover and flare
that I gave you at seven cents
you did myself that was fantastic
um I think we're going to know about
this event uh
thank you all for joining us that have
managed to stay long I know we went over
but I couldn't help myself so that's my
fault but you could have dropped off
anytime you wanted but obviously there's
a lot of gas to be flared and we did a
great job today so thank you so much for
joining us
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu